[Musik]
donnerstagmorgen 27
februar das corona virus ist im
bündnerland angekommen
der kantonale führungsstab ist ab sofort
aktiv martin bühler ist dessen chef
sieht gäste arbeit vor den zwei
bestätigte fall
und da damit einmal mehr ein eskalation
mainzer größte dass das controller
darauf vorbereitet jetzt ist aber nötig
spezifisch sich auf die neue situation
musste richter las begleiter ist
cristian florin leiter infrastruktur der
rhätischen bahn
das zugpersonal ist bereits über
hygienische massnahmen instruiert worden
danke meinen jetzt sind wir schockiert
kreis kleve
aber der informations und internet und
zu nutzen
die situation neu ordnen
was kann dort wo sie wirklich der worst
case etwas mehr problemen vor allem im
grenzüberschreitenden verkehr das ist
schlecht daran dass reportern in der
entscheidung dass er ein sitz mit der
sbb linie und zweiter stelle vor dass
man mit dem boot dass man kläre mit dem
zug schränken ali steht dass man ganz
klar wenn abstimmen mit dem bogen die
beiden sind unterwegs zu einer
krisensitzung
sie haben die familien bewohnen die
macht
wir sind informiert über die maßnahme
wurde strafen sind nur die ans gefühl
wenn man das so machen die seite der
familien passieren
[Musik]
regierungsrat peter peyer vorsteher des
departements justiz sicherheit und
gesundheit informiert wie das corona
virus in den kanton graubünden kam
kinder nehmen zu dem kanton diverse
verdachtsfällen aber auch schwarzweiß
negativ erwiesen da in den zahlen
ständiger pflicht was man machen werden
wenn man am dreieck meint informieren
und sänger dass man in der region und in
der wasserball bestäuber wiener misano
von die maßnahmen griffen kairos alles
das heißt insbesondere keine frauen
laufen sonntag drei fasnacht
veranstaltungen statt normal wieder
kreise ins landschaftsbild es sinn der
maßnahme gelten als einzigartig zweiter
märz und am mächtig den verlaufen darf
man ohne beurteilung und mieter was wird
insbesondere von das ist der größte ist
was mit
wir glauben dass er in der woche
stattfindet erklärt hat jedoch das
sondern entscheidet danach was ist der
größte schaden und in der wirtschaft
oder von geld sondern verfügte jeder
teilnehmer für alle da ist kann das
gericht ihn entweder für marathon hofer
zum kongo helfer die ganzen umfeld
involviert dann aber ich verstehe sie
nicht
also das ist inkonsequent schur jahres
von letzter woche gestartet die runde
beschließt schweren herzens den
engadiner skimarathon abzusagen
der vorläufige höhepunkt einer
entwicklung welche die medien seit einem
guten monat intensiv beschäftigt in
china breitet sich eine bisher nicht
bekannte lungenkrankheit aus in diesem
tier markt in wohin habe alles begonnen
berichten die medien
das neuartige corona virus sei vom tier
auf den menschen übergesprungen
anfang dezember werden die ersten
infizierten in die spitäler der stadt
eingeliefert
am 23 januar dann der shutdown
die elf millionen stadt wo hahn wer
thermisch abgeriegelt heute wissen wir
das virus wenn er trotzdem einen weg von
johann in die ganze welt
das bundesamt für gesundheit rechnet von
anfang an damit dass es wohl auch wieder
schweiz corona fälle geben wird
die frage ist nur wann und wie viele
im moment ist es unmöglich mit jetzigen
information gesichert zu sagen wo die
reise hingeht das nationale
referenzlabor in genf macht sich bereit
um proben von verdachtsfällen zu testen
shanghai am vergangenen freitag
sf korrespondentin claudia stein macht
sich auf den weg um einen beitrag zu
filmen
sie hat eine spezial karte erhalten die
sie vorweisen muss wenn sie auf dem haus
will
in shanghai gibt es mittlerweile zeichen
der entspannung
immer mehr läden öffnen wieder laut whu
ist der höhepunkt der epidemie in china
überschritten
aber man müsse weiter wachsam sein es
ist noch ein langer weg zurück zur
normalität aber langsam kehrt das
öffentliche leben zurück diese bar ist
ab sofort wieder geöffnet ganz zur
freude des italienischen besitzers
man hat uns informiert dass wir wieder
aufmachen dürfen
ich denke das generelle ziel ist dass
wir langsam und geordnet zum auftakt
zurück während sich die lage in weiten
teilen chinas allmählich entspannt
spitzt sie sich in europa laufend zu in
immer mehr ländern gibt es bestätigte
corona fälle in rehna verfolgt man
natürlich was passiert in europa metern
corona virus aber es geht jetzt quasi
selbst kritik dass man sich fragt warum
heim ist nicht geschafft dass sich das
virus aber nicht aus der van triel und
seitige kritik der medien und natürlich
vorsicht regiert
das war das zeichen von schwäche und
passt natürlich nicht zum selbstbild
wochen vor sich hat dass man das macht
ist auch okay vom besten filme dank man
hier sogar spezielle jetzt kommt der
westen bis vor einer lehre im umgang mit
dem virus in china passierte lange
nichts dann wurde entschlossenheit
demonstriert die millionenstadt wo hand
zum beispiel ist weiter abgeriegelt
ein einziger schweizer ist noch vor ort
zusammen mit seiner chinesischen frau
und seinen kindern
wir sind seit einem monat in horn
eingeschlossen
die schlimmen fälle werden den spitälern
behandelt die leichteren sind in einer
isolationszelle damit sie die anderen
nicht anstecken
bei uns klingt das regelmäßig an der tür
dann überprüfen die behörden unsere
temperatur alle sind ständig unter
beobachtung das ist klar
anfangs durfte er noch jeden dritten tag
einkaufen gehen
damit ist es jetzt vorbei seit einer
woche sind er und seine familie in der
wohnung blockiert sie dürfe nur noch den
abfall rausbringen das essen müssen sie
im internet bestellen jeden fünften tag
gibt es eine lieferung die sie abholen
dürfen dann müssen sie zurück in ihre
wohnung
[Musik]
inzwischen ist das virus auch in europa
angekommen
seit einer woche werden in italien ganze
orte abgeriegelt keiner kommt mehr ins
sperrgebiet und keiner mehr raus
normalität derweil an der schweizer
grenze zu italien besondere maßnahmen
sind hier keine geplant es war nur noch
eine frage der zeit jetzt aber hat auch
die schweiz ihrem ersten corona virus
fall ein 70 jähriger tessiner wird auf
das virus positiv getestet er wird in
einer privatklinik in lugano in
quarantäne genommen aus der er
inzwischen wieder entlassen wurde
medienkonferenz mit dem tessiner
kantonsarzt als der erste schweizer fall
bestätigt ist der zustand des
infizierten sei stabil sagte er den
journalisten
doch george melanie ist nervös seit
tagen spitzt sich die lage zu es ist
eine gratwanderung zwischen
beschwichtigen und aufklären über den
ernst der lage ist das eingetroffen was
wir vorausgesagt haben
es war nur eine frage der zeit das brg
informiert parallel darüber dass der
infizierte tessiner vor seiner
einlieferung ins spital engen kontakt
mit seiner familie gehabt habe es sei
möglich dass andere angesteckt wurden
viele verlässlich steckt niemand also
von dem her kann man jetzt noch nicht
sagen ob diese fall andré angesteckt hat
selbstverständlich müssen jetzt alle
kontaktpersonen aufgesucht werden und 14
tage in quarantäne genommen werden
laut dem direktor des bundesamtes für
gesundheit werden wegen des tessiner
falles aber wieder schulen geschlossen
noch sportveranstaltungen abgesagt
eine informationskampagne reiche derzeit
aus
sollte sich dies auf die ganze schweiz
ausbreiten hätten wir eine besondere
lage mit massnahmen die der bundesrat
beschließen müsste vorbereitet sein für
eine pandemie
der pandemieplan des bundes zeigt welche
maßnahmen bei einer starken ausbreitung
theoretisch möglich wären
schulschließungen veranstaltungs verbote
und mit vorschriften können öffentliche
oder private unternehmen geschlossen und
ganze gebiete oder regionen abgeriegelt
werden derart weitreichende maßnahmen
würde der bundesrat festlegen
voraussetzung dafür wäre eine sogenannte
besondere lage die das ganze land
betrifft
alles ist möglich schon die die haupt
maxime die hauptpriorität für den
bundesrat ist einfach die gesundheit der
bevölkerung zu schützen
donnerstagnachmittag am 27 februar
martin bühler als zum nächsten termin
der chef des kantonalen führungsstabes
und weitere entscheidungsträger treten
vor die versammelte presse zeigt dass es
sich um eine sache handelt die von
großem interesse ist was am morgen im
kleinen kreis besprochen wurde wird nun
öffentlich gemacht
eine möglichst transparente
kommunikation soll vertrauen schaffen
was machen wir zurzeit einerseits geht
es jetzt seit gestern darum die
kommunikationsbedürfnisse die ansteigen
zu befriedigen sage ich umfassend zu
informieren das gesundheitsamt dabei zu
unterstützen dies zu tun sie haben ja
gesehen beispielsweise wurde jetzt diese
webseite auf der kantons seite speziell
fürs corona videos aufgeschaltet durch
die pressekonferenz wird martin bühler
zur öffentlichen figur der leiter des
amtes für militär und zivilschutz ist
ein gefragter mann
martin wierig es nötig dass mit der npd
skimarathon abgleitet mehreren leuten
vertrag von noka die entscheidungsmacht
abgewogen und sind zum schluss dass es
nötig ist und hauptaufgabe den
restaurants zeigt sich dass man
unterstützen die kommunikations
verstärken
ich glaube es ganz wichtig dass man die
menschen darum gut informieren und sagen
das schütteln der beitrag leisten dass
sich selber nicht ausbreitet nicht nur
die medien haben derzeit fragen an
bühler sondern auch die chefs von
anderen kantonalen führen steben was
macht denn sind infrastruktur
identifizierten immer größer
ja ich muss ja nicht wenig ab denn wenn
ich haben sich zum beispiel denken
sondern was man auch ihrem besten zu uns
möglichst lang blieb also dass ich sage
jetzt wenn du dir hausgeist hunderte und
tausende
wenn man den wahrscheinlich gesamt bund
koordiniert
okay was machen würde
der bündner pandemieplan wurde 2015
letztmals überarbeitet und 2017
durchexerziert darin geht es auch im
lager wie dieses wo alles bereit ist für
den fall dass sich die situation weiter
verschärft also setzte ich glaube der
schutzmaske wir als medizinische maske
und mir händ möglichkeit überprüfung
bundesamt für bevölkerungsschutz
wirklich für notfall- und für höhere
priorisierung maske mit höhere qualität
jetzt stelle
und die haben sofort gebucht machen von
der möglichkeit die sind auch orte sind
eher gering ein
kannst du zu genau und dass das sind
darin offen legen wir darauf vorbereitet
das sind der schutzmasken vor einer
prüfung der musikstücke und auch sind 50
uhr zwei bis drei stunden denkt von
diesem raum aus könnte der kanton die
fragen der bevölkerung beantworten
während zehn telefonanschluss warum
redet aktivpartner zu jedem telefon
bräuchte er dennoch einen telefonisten
defizit wenn es wirklich schwer moskau
könnte man sie auch der hinterste dass
ihm ein tumor sofort auf abruf beraten
ich spreche innerhalb von ein bis zwei
stunden werden sie sicher braucht
während einsatzbereit unternehmer das
sind rund 13 personen und dann nochmal
rund 21 euro innerhalb von drei bis
sechs stunden die rocker könnten bei
bedarf das corona virus verunsichert die
schweiz
ob es tatsächlich zu einer pandemie
kommt ist allerdings offen
die derzeitige situation erinnert an
bekannte frühere virus fälle wie sars
oder vogelgrippe
es beginnt jeweils mit krankheits und
todesfällen in fremden ländern oft
leiden und sterben zunächst asiatische
menschen an bis dahin noch unbekannten
hochansteckenden virus erkrankungen
gegen diese gibt es keinen schutz in
formen
diese viren verbreiten sich dann
weltweit und sorgen für beunruhigung
auch in der schweiz die geheimnisvolle
und gefährliche asiatische pneumonie
oder lungenentzündungen sie seit einigen
tagen europa erreicht hat sei eine
weltweite bedrohung die angst vor der
hühner grippe geht auch in der schweiz
um die furcht vor der ausbreitung der
gefährlichen lungenerkrankungen saß
durch flugreisende wächst bisher sind
über zehn menschen an der rätselhafte
lungenentzündung gestorben
die schweiz rüstet sich dann jeweils für
den worst case krankheits und
übertragungsrate von anfang an eindämmen
heißt die devise im rückblick wirkt
manche reaktion übertrieben
ihre konturen meist basel jeder sechste
zu hoch und es im asiatischen raum
besonderer kurs auf engem raum ist da
steckst vor für kranke große jeder dank
dem lebensgefährlichen virus asia dieser
hysterie bekommen zurzeit vor allem
apotheker zu spüren die leute decken
sich mit tamiflu ein völlig unnötiger
weise sagen die experten des bundes fakt
ist hierzulande sterben weit mehr
menschen an herkömmlichen grippe
erkrankungen
[Musik]
sobald die virus tragenden tiere einmal
ausgemacht sind kommt es zu
massentötungen
die ursprungsländer wollen der welt
damit auch zeigen dass sie das problem
im griff haben
forscher beginnen nach impfstoffen zu
suchen
[Musik]
wie hier in taiwan werden vermeintliche
siege über viruserkrankungen wie sars
öffentlich zelebriert bis diese oder
eine andere dann doch wieder auftauchen
[Musik]
wird diesmal alles anders christian
althaus epidemien forscher an der uni
bern schreibt auf twitter
die wissenschaftliche fehleinschätzung
des bhg zur gefährlichkeit des corona
virus sei unverantwortlich
in der nzz sagte er zwei tage später die
meisten fachleute gehen wie ich davon
aus dass die sterblichkeit bei rund
einem prozent liegt das wären etwa zehn
mal so viele todesfälle wie bei einer
normalen grippe
und weil es keine immunität in der
bevölkerung gebe könnten sich bis zu 40
prozent der leute anstecken
es könnte also drei millionen infizierte
und 30.000 tote geben rechnet die nzz
vor und althaus antwortet ja ein solches
worst case szenario ist nicht
ausgeschlossen also mittels risiko das
messer steckte moderat bis jetzt das
risiko dass ich natürlich jetzt zieht
andere was wir nicht machen ist
hypothetisch italia fallzahlen über
sterblichkeits zahlen will das basiert
auf modell- und mehr probieren mit der
wirklichkeit mit der achten staffel
freitagmorgen 28 februar report des
kantonalen führungsstabes konnten
jetzt bevorzuge
morgen ist dann werden so viele zähler
und viel reden wie lange denn jeder lage
analysieren es ist nur wichtig sondern
auch gestern oder wie sie seine
geknechteten schiesssportverband mode
der fotos machen oder nicht der fall so
schüchtern dass er klar und
wahrscheinliche la die entwicklung
senida star zahl von abzuklären
verdachtsfälle internet stadthagen
stieger wird in einigen tagen kunst so
mal starker anstieg erkrankung aufgrund
von lokale über dreckige knapp gehörter
wie hygiene master unter die situations
mittel werde der nächste hausse
verkaufen oder sie zum teil schon
grossanlässe und massa massa freistaat
in den kommenden wochen wir und abseits
wieder zum tauschobjekt verunsicherung
in der bevölkerung steigt also ich mit
direkter ursel berger vom öffentlichen
lebens rechner und mediale interesse
nimmt wieder zu und bildet entsprechende
ressource schutzmaske gesicht gehört sie
im umgang mit lasters in die sitzung des
kantonalen führungsstabes platzt die
nachricht dass der bundesrat eine
sogenannte besondere lage ausgerufen hat
mit der verordnung über massnahmen zur
bekämpfung des kronos es ist verboten
öffentliche oder private veranstaltungen
bei der sich gleichzeitig mehr als 1000
personen aufhalten in der schweiz
durchzuführen
mehr als die mehr als 1000 ist eine
folgenschwere entscheidung aus bern
bundesrat alle börse erklärt sich den
medien ist wirklich nicht einfach so ein
schritt zu tun
aber in der abwägung die wir gemacht
haben den bundesrat sind jetzt zum
schluss gekommen ich werde die nächsten
zwei wochen es ist nicht viel aber zwei
wochen vielleicht wird es verlängert
vielleicht vieles verändert aber die
nächsten zwei wochen müssen wir das sehr
starke aufpassen weil oberste priorität
ist schutz der bevölkerung der
gesundheit der öffentliche gesundheit
wenn er es trotzdem zu ansteckungen
kommt sind die spitäler gefordert sicher
wo man sich apparat sind sofort martin
bühler als nächster programmpunkt an
diesem tag er lässt sich vom chefarzt
des spitals auf den neuesten stand der
vorbereitungen bringen und doha modernes
überdruck also unter druck zimmer mit
filter das heißt luft vor inne fonds
immer konfuser und luft verursachung
diene druckt ihn willst du unter druck
hätten
und da würde man die hersteller bringen
gott ihnen präsentiert sich unser
mitarbeiter gar oder wie schon
vorbereitet wenn es telefonisch ist also
schon gut geschützt und der gott der
mensch der sie höre wie es durchsucht
und macht also ein bisschen super
ausgestattet aber natürlich vor dem
jerusalemer im bescheidenen rahmen
im gegensatz zu groß später aber das ist
ja sagen aber irgend mit der u2 die
herren jolly labbadia würden die haben
nämlich alle gebiete und mir ein
tatsächlich haben wir so maske dass er
wo überall losgegangen ist das ist
cantonas genutzte sieht unter der bund
und das wird jetzt alles organisiert und
erhöht die erste lieferung schon wieder
machen damit man keine unsere
möglichkeiten offen also unsere
materialien
das ist also das finde wichtig
die kapazitätsgrenze wäre schnell
erreicht knapp 20 erkrankte könnte das
spital schiers aufnehmen
[Musik]